yeah so I think a sense of humor is
really a very very good tour of you in a
teaching so so I use the insert
interesting figures in my slides then
people will be really focusing on your
slides and your lecture and that because
people don't want to miss the joke right
and also lab makes the lecture much more
enjoyable as well because everybody
wants to learn things happily okay so
and also those jokes I insert most of
the time that they are relevant physics
interpretation of those jokes so that's
actually my idea to make the lecture
much more enjoyable and also keeping the
students very focused and the material
recovered so my idea is to have a much
more relaxed customer-owned so that you
can actually then people feel that they
can ask whatever questions they have
because I not like super serious I mean
asking for everybody to keep quiet
we cannot react to any funny things
right I have been doing from here
I should be Maxwell see the light can
you see it maybe not yet maybe we're
slightly slower than Maxwell but but we
will see that together in this lecture
first of all I will feel very relaxed
because I ever I want to help the
students and also the students will feel
that there's racial passing questions
were greatly reduced if the instructor
is actually very funny very very
humorous so that's actually my idea and
which drive me to the decision to insert
a lot of interesting
pictures and the jokes during the
lecture